let's hear from a few more folks in the
audience for the first time in 2023 we
take calls via Discord davidpackman.com
Discord you can join the waiting Lobby
if you want to talk to me you can raise
your hand almost like fifth grade all
over again which is exciting let's go to
melody in Missouri melody in Missouri
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today and thank you for being a
website member by the way I very much
appreciate that
all right Melody may be gone that's too
bad
I was looking forward to speaking with
Melody let's instead go to JWR from
Atlanta Georgia JWR welcome I know you
won't let us down
no of course not
um happy to um
um
um I'm I'm happy that you were that you
were able to happy to be here um I hope
hope you're enjoying your new year
um sorry if I sing good for that kid I'm
just kind of um watching all the chaos
unfold as they as see I'm uh as McCarthy
as McCarthy um proof uh like I think he
was Einstein who said that who defined
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting a different
results and Republicans have certainly
been doing that this week
yes okay so regardless of how this turns
out what do you think
um I regardless of how this turns out
what do you think is like I guess I
guess house Democrats best chance of
like using the chaos that is inevitably
going to unfold in their in their in in
their in their favor when it comes to
the next election cycle Here's my
thought okay
uh Republicans are going to try to
obstruct Democrats from getting anything
done and then in 2024 they're going to
say don't vote for these Democrats they
didn't get anything done the opportunity
for Democrats here given that Democrats
will control the Senate do not control
the house but it's very close in the
house is there should be situations
where it's either going to be uh some
kind of spending bill made up mostly of
Common Sense stuff that all Americans
want or we might get a debt ceiling
situation or we are going to have things
come up in the next couple of years
where Democrats in the House and Senate
are going to be United with the American
people in the Senate that will be one
situation because Democrats control it
what's going on
sorry are you talking to someone else or
to me
oh no it's background noise oh geez okay
uh I so the point I'm trying to make is
democrats should have some opportunities
to really make Republicans look very
stupid and unnecessarily obstructionist
in opposition to some bills that the
entire American public will mostly be in
favor of Democrats have to just be
prepared to take advantage of those
opportunities to be able to fight back
in 24 against the narrative that
Democrats got nothing done thanks to
Republicans Force Republicans to either
give you some wins or really make
themselves look like they don't have the
interests of the American people uh uh
in mind if they do get in the way of
every single thing Democrats try to do I
think that's the one and only
opportunity
yes and I would also like to add like
well not giving them any time to eat
like any easy or obvious wins that could
that that could um
just as long as we don't do the thing
where it's what we somehow managed to to
snatch the feet from the jaws of Victory
which is not completely which is not as
important which is not impossible
that's absolutely absolutely the case
JWR thank you for the call I appreciate
it
of course always happy to be here
JWR from Atlanta Georgia wow